aquí tenemos una circunferencia de
perímetro 18 pi es decir si recorremos
alrededor toda la circunferencia
en total recorremos 18 y vale y además
del perímetro también tenemos un ángulo
central es decir un ángulo cuyo vértice
está en el centro de la circunferencia
algo de ese estilo vale y pensemos que
además nos dicen que la medida de este
ángulo central es 10 grados bueno con
esta información lo que me interesa es
determinar la longitud del arco que
queda suspendido por este ángulo central
es decir de este cachito de la
circunferencia bueno para pensar esto
resulta que este cachito es proporcional
a que tanto abrimos en este ángulo
déjame escribirlo aquí con él con una
fórmula para que sea más claro la
longitud del arco
la longitud del arco
del arco dividida entre el perímetro de
la circunferencia entre el perímetro
perímetro
es igual es igual a la medida del ángulo
central la medida del ángulo central que
se extiende el arco a ángulo
central entre la cantidad central entre
la cantidad de grados totales que tiene
una circunferencia es decir entre 360
grados bueno con esta fórmula ya podemos
resolver el problema sustituyendo los
valores que conocemos en vez de poner de
poner la longitud de arco deja de
ponerle simplemente a saleh para no
escribir tanto entonces a dividido entre
el perímetro que es 18 pin 18 pi es
igual a la medida del ángulo central o
sea 10 grados dividido entre 360 grados
y a partir de aquí podemos despejar a
multiplicando ambos lados por 18 pib
aquí multiplicamos por 18 pi de este
lado también por 18 pi de este lado se
cancelan y de esta forma nos queda que a
lo voy a poner de este lado que es igual
a este 10 con este 360 se hace uno entre
36 18 entre 36 es un medio entonces nos
queda que es igual a pi pi medios muy
bien vamos a resolver otro problema
déjame tomar otra circunferencia vamos a
pensar que otra vez tiene perímetro 18
pi valen 18 pi y que una vez tenemos una
vez más tenemos un ángulo central
tenemos un ángulo central algo de este
estilo
pero el que nos interesa es el grandote
vale el que es obtuso el de este lado e
imagínate que nos dicen que nos dicen
que la medida de ese ángulo es 350
grados 350 grados es un ángulo muy muy
obtuso bueno vamos a ver cuánto mide
ahora la longitud de este arco el que
nos interesa es este de acá china se
está quedando un poco chueco voy a
hacerlo por cachitos porque si no no me
va a salir entonces más o menos algo así
se requiere un poco de práctica aquí
quedó feo pero bueno espero que se vea
la idea más o menos algo de ese estilo
vale entonces una vez más vamos a
aplicar esta fórmula tenemos que a la
longitud de arco dividida entre el
perímetro que otra vez es 18 pin 18 pi
es igual a la medida del ángulo central
que ahora sería 350 grados 350 grados
dividido entre 360 grados que es la
cantidad total de grados en un círculo
360 grados vale una vez más
multiplicando por 18
de ambos lados aquí y acá tenemos que
este se cancela con este y por lo tanto
es igual a pues vamos a ver aquí el 0 se
cancela con el 0 18 entre 36 otra vez es
un medio entonces nos queda que an
es igual
10 y 35 35 medios por pi
muy bien y si te das cuenta todo tiene
sentido 35 medios de pie es lo mismo que
es lo mismo que el 17.5 y 17.5 pi aquí
arriba y medios es lo mismo que 0.5 pin
0.5 pi y entonces si sumamos esta
longitud de arco con esta longitud de
arco de acá nos queda 17 puntos 5.5 o
sea 18 pi y eso tiene todo el sentido
del mundo porque 18 pies el perímetro y
estos ángulos 10 más 350 suman los 360
grados que tiene una circunferencia